alors tout de suite retour à la liesse
cet après midi sans les champs elysées
avec la remontée des joueurs de l'équipe
de france après avoir déjeuné avenue
d'iéna au siège de la fédération
française de football ils sont montés
dans un bus découvert à plateforme pour
remonter les champs elysées présentation
sous forme de clip
peggy leroy et jean laurent serra
benoît
ah ah
vas-y voilà
ouais
ronaldo est un des dix heures tu
apparais qui sera ouvert et aucune
référence le passé rien côté ça fait
soixante quatre ans que les français
attendent d'être au final on n'est plus
à une heure près
c'est sa première coupe du monde paul
tibbets là aussi ils doivent passer ils
vont passer c'est sûr pourquoi ils
passeraient pas me fait pas peur comme
ça
ouais
oui
hello
merci